I know people who like uh like two or
three of my close friends they're like
entertainment Source was y'all guys as
[__] like
yeah they don't watch Netflix they don't
watch Hulu they'll just be like [__]
oh no jumper you know it's very
entertaining no it's crazy it's like I
mean I I told Adam that I was like dude
it feels like how like Howard Stern was
back in the day because Howard Stern
used to have like [__] 10 different
wild ass characters that were part of
this morning he had things that you
couldn't do in 2023 right a lot yeah he
had chicks riding Uncle yeah but
nonetheless it was uh it was crazy for
sure
um so for for you guys like
um
what's is it you is it you guys are
business partners is pun a part of it is
he just managing it because if you look
at that that channel it's pun's face
right in the middle oh yeah but I
changed that [__] now hey defense
even how that happened so originally we
didn't know if duno was going you know
what I'm saying stick around right so at
the time it was just going to be like we
started pushing fig community and when
it originally had the pictures it had um
I think it was
t-rail
um pun it was smack and meat it was four
so when Dino said [__] it I'm with the
guys we just added him to the side so
just so it makes everybody it made it it
made it look like yeah pun was in the
middle of the situation but yeah
Community world you know just back on
fig you know I'm saying community and
then the world is doing old world that's
why we added the world because Facebook
you know Ace boys you know I'm saying
Ace boys worldwide so we added the world
because everybody's gonna be on there
collectively you know I'm saying they're
gonna have a show on there but yeah the
main people will be me A.D smack Dino
and punk because we curate a lot of [__]
as far as you know the content